The ending of the original Blade Runner has
been hotly debated by fans for years.
A combination of vague hints from director
Ridley Scott and all kinds of studio meddling
resulted in viewers being split on just what
we were supposed to pull from the end of the
1982 sci-fi film.
And now that Denis Villeneuve's Blade Runner
2049 has arrived, there's plenty more dystopian
ambiguity for viewers to pick apart for years
to come.
Here are our best guesses and interpretations
as to what exactly — probably — the ending
of the film really meant, and where the franchise
might go from here…or if it'll go anywhere
at all.
And it should go without saying: major spoilers
ahead.
Decoy Boy
There's a lot in Blade Runner 2049 that simply
goes unsaid, meaning that untangling and unpacking
some of the plot's details and revelations
is going to be a little fuzzy — just like
the original.
But one thing seems pretty clear by the time
the credits roll: Ryan Gosling's character,
K, is the decoy Replicant made of Deckard
and Rachael's daughter, Ana.
We can glean from the clues K follows throughout
the story that there is a decoy, and before
the big revelation near the end we're meant
to think that the decoy was a girl, and was
dead.
Sure, the leader of the Replicant rebellion,
Freysa, never points her finger at K and says,
"you, guy with the weird face — you're definitely
the Replicant decoy."
Still, we can piece together just enough information
to know who K is, and what role he was always
meant to play.
K was implanted with Ana's memory of the wooden
horse and the orphanage, so if anyone followed
the clues to find the missing baby, they'd
end up finding K — the boy that was listed
as alive.
Genuine Joi
Blade Runner's whole schtick has always been
asking about what it means to be human.
What defines life?
Is a person a person only if he or she comes
from standard babymaking procedures?
Are we more than the sum of our biology?
But in all the excitement of meeting K, unearthing
Deckard in Vegas, and lots of punching in
the rain, one character's journey into humanity
should definitely not be overlooked.
Joi, played by Ana de Armas, is K's holographic
girlfriend, an artificial intelligence he
bought from the big robot store.
As the story progresses, we see Joi transform
into a true companion for K, who even says
she loves him right before her death.
"We have to go."
"I'm coming with you."
Later on, K sees an advertisement for Joi,
and he starts to doubt whether or not she
— and her feelings — were ever real at
all.
And those are the very same kinds of questions
he's asking about himself.
Both movies ask us to take K and the other
Replicants' quest for humanity and personhood
as something that's plausibly attainable — despite
the fact that they're made in a factory and
implanted with memories and programmed.
And if we do, then we have to also believe
that Joi is capable of the same growth as
an actual person, regardless of whether or
not she's got an actual body.
What's in a name?
It's impossible to look at the names of two
of Blade Runner 2049's most prominent female
characters — Joi and Luv — and not see
them as highly symbolic.
Joi was something that K longed for, and could
only find as a prepackaged product that he
could buy.
Ultimately, Joi was something he could only
see and hear, but never actually touch.
And by the end, his Joi is crushed by Luv.
And Luv, as we see throughout the film, is
both beautiful and cruel.
By the end, K literally grapples with Luv
and drowns her, all to save Deckard and reunite
him with his daughter.
For Deckard's love to live, he has to destroy
Luv himself.
The Deckard question
If you thought Blade Runner 2049 would settle
the Deckard debate once and for all…well,
think again.
In terms of the original Blade Runner, director
Ridley Scott says Deckard is a replicant,
while actor Harrison Ford says he isn't.
And even though the various non-theatrical
cuts of the film heavily imply that Deckard's
memories are implants, we're never told for
sure.
Well, don't find out in Blade Runner 2049
either — but there are plenty of insinuations
and implications that let viewers speculate.
For instance, Deckard tells K
"We were being hunted!"
That certainly implies that they were two
rogue skin-jobs on the run.
But the fact that he loved Rachael and then
went and fathered her robo-baby is also enough
to make anyone — replicant, human, or otherwise
— stay in hiding.
Wallace, too, suggests that Deckard was programmed
to meet and fall in love with Rachael so they
could create a baby together.
But we never get confirmation that this was
what happened in the original movie, and we're
left to keep speculating.
But it's better that we don't know for sure
whether Deckard is a Replicant.
After all, the main point of these films is
to ask the question of what it means to be
human, right?
It's not really necessary to be told about
Deckard's origins.
It's far more interesting and symbolically
effective to leave it ambiguous.
In fact, answering the question would kinda
ruin the movie, wouldn't it?
Another sequel?
They Repli-can't resist
If this latest sequel performs well — and
its excellent reviews seem to indicate it
will — there's no reason to think the studio
won't hop to work on making a third movie.
One of the best aspects of this film was the
way it continued to build the world we only
saw hints of in Ridley Scott's original.
And leaving Deckard and his daughter Ana alive
at the end of the film means Wallace could
still find and capture them for his nefarious
ends.
Plus, we've got a whole Replicant rebellion
waiting to kick off.
Better reserve your ticket for Blade Runner
3: Revenge of the Replicants now, before they
sell out.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this other cool stuff we
know you'll love too.